we are a mere twenty five days into the
Donald Trump presidency and there are
already multiple not casual but really
serious investigations into different
aspects of what's going on each more
serious than the last we've already
discussed that it has been revealed that
the Donald Trump team was in constant
contact with Russians during the
campaign Russian intelligence sources
which is highly unusual and we have
multiple intelligence agencies
investigating that very very serious
next we have the House Oversight
Committee which has launched their own
investigation into Donald Trump's
possible security breaches when he was
discussing on the patio at Merrill
mar-a-lago in Florida of what was going
on with a North Korean nuclear but not
nuclear a ballistics missile test and
there's an investigation going on into
that jason Chaffetz is part of that
investigation I want to address jason
Chaffetz his involvement the Republican
congressman a little bit more next we
have the office of government ethics
director Walter shall be recommending
that the White House investigate Donald
Trump senior advisor Kellyanne Conway
because it appears that she committed a
quote clear violation of ethics rules
when she promoted Ivanka Trump's
clothing line on Fox News last week
saying quote I recommend that the White
House investigate his Conway's actions
and considered taking disciplinary
action against her could Kellyanne
Conway be the next to go from the Trump
administration some suggestions that
it's rinsed Priebus Reince rinse rice
Reince Priebus who might be the next to
go you'll recall that Kellyanne Conway
said eight hours before Michael Flynn
resigned in shame that the president has
complete trust in Flynn hours later
press secretary Sean Spicer said Michael
Flynn was asked to resign because the
president lost trust in him there's one
other aspect so a number of it were 25
days in we have at minimum three really
way more if you count each intelligence
agency sort of has its own investigation
investigations into the Donald Trump
administration there's the idea floating
around that everything but the Russia
stuff is a distraction and that that's
why jason Chaffetz is getting behind the
nuclear football investigation from
mar-a-lago
because really the goal here is to take
away attention from the really serious
thing which is possible collusion with
Russia during the campaign well it's a
good thing that Chase is at least
getting involved in one of these
scandals on paper I mean just dis
contrast this to the Obama
administration Obama kind of got away
with saying that he ran his presidency
scandal-free which wasn't so true and
I'm not talking about the IRS scandal or
the Benghazi cover-up but with regards
to the NSA and with the drone program
yes but I mean relatively much fewer
than you know what we have seen so far
in Trump's present in 25 days there's
already more scandals during the two
weeks leading up to the inauguration
Trump had more scandals than President
Obama in his entire two terms very very
scary what's going on send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show